If you, I know you didn't just call out
the purple [music] and gold.
>> You
You You sure you one of us?
You uh
You sure you You sure you You in the
right place, dog? Do you remember what
happened to the last brother that called
out the purple and gold? Oh, I know
exactly what happened last time we
challenged the purple and gold Rangers.
Y'ALL ARE IDIOTS. THIS is stupid, man.
Okay. Hey, this is stupid.
>> this down cuz I I appreciate that.
>> Wait a minute.
>> I Can I respond to that?
>> No.
>> Hold on. Wait. Listen, cuz you keep
using this word.
>> just went off on Christianity, but
you're not getting your facts right.
>> cuz it's EVERY HEY, HEY, GUESS THIS.
WATCH THIS. Watch this. Hey, so watch
this. So, the angels are are God, too?
See?
That's what happened. But you already
started something you can't finish. The
trinity you believe in is that Christ is
co-eternal and co-equal with the Father.
Trash.
Now, I'm proud of you, actually, man.
You actually got our belief correct,
that we believe that Jesus is co-eternal
and co-equal with the Father. You're
absolutely right. But here's what my
guess is. My guess is that you don't
even know what this means. You don't
know what Christians mean by co-eternal
and co-equal. So, when we say that the
Father and the Son are co-equal, we're
saying that they're co-equal in
substance, in their nature, in their
essence. Meaning that they can have a
different role where the Son humbles
himself to the Father, but that doesn't
negate that he is equal with the Father
within his essence. Meaning because he's
equal with the Father in substance,
that's why he is also eternal like the
Father is because the Father's substance
is eternal, is infinite. So, with that
being said, I think it's about that time
we get ready for our culinary arts.
Let's get this started. Hey, babe. All
that apologetics you're reading, but
they don't what? Understand. Let's break
it down. Colossians 1:15. It says, "Who
is the image of the invisible God and
the firstborn of every creature?" So,
Christ is not co-eternal with the
Father. He was the first creature,
firstborn of God. All right? See, this
is the same pot that all the Hebrew
Israelites put themselves in, man. Let
me show you guys how the Bible works.
When you're talking about the Bible and
using a word in the Bible, you got to
use the context to see how the word is
used. So, right here his argument is
Jesus is called the firstborn of
creation. He's called the firstborn of
every creature. Therefore, he must be
the first creature, right? Well, let's
see what the Bible says. When we go to
Psalm 89, talking about David, God says
this in verse 20. He says, "I have found
David, my servant. I have anointed him
with my sacred oil." When we jump down
to the 27th verse, watch what he says
here about David. "I will also make him
my firstborn,
the highest of the kings of the earth."
Now, hold on a second. David was the
youngest of his brothers, nor was he the
first king of the earth. He wasn't even
the first king of Israel. So, how is it
that David is the firstborn, the highest
of the kings of the earth? Well, it
literally tells us that he is the
highest of the kings of the earth. So,
firstborn is not being used literally
here. It's being used as a station of
supremacy. Let's use another example.
Joseph had two sons, Manasseh and
Ephraim. Now, which one does God say is
the firstborn? Because literally the
firstborn is Manasseh. Ephraim's the
youngest. But let's go ahead and jump
over here to Jeremiah 31. When we look
over here in verse nine, this is what
God says about Ephraim. He says, "They
will come weeping, but I will bring them
back with consolation. I will lead them
to waters to with water by a smooth way
where they will not stumble. For I am
Israel's father, and Ephraim is my
firstborn." Hold on a second, God.
Ephraim is the youngest son. So, instead
of putting yourself in the same trap,
why don't you ask the Bible how is the
word being used in its context? But I'm
pretty sure you're going to explain that
in your next clip, right? Now, I know
context matters to God logic as it does
with us. Verse 16 gives a little more
context. It says, "For by him, Christ,
[music]
were all things created." Now, I know
what the apologetic wants to do. If all
things were created by Christ, then how
was Christ himself created? Yeah, that's
a good question. You missed the point.
Let's keep reading. It says, "For by him
are all things created that are in
heaven and that are in earth." That's a
distinction. When Christ was brought
forth first from the Father, he then
created all things, heaven and earth.
Remember, God the Father and God the Son
stood outside of time.
Was he serious?
I
I think he was serious.
>> There's no way he was serious. He just
Yeah, you should You should respond to
that. I But he just like Brother, he he
he just said that
God the Father and God the Son
>> but he he may not know.
You think You think he knew? I There's
no way he knew. He's
There's no way he knew like with the way
he said it.
>> I think I think I should respond to
that?
>> he wants you to Okay. Okay. I'll
respond.
All right. Let me just do this over.
God the who?
>> God the Son. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. God
the what?
>> God the Son. Wait. So So, you mean So,
God the Father and God the Son? So, you
In In the middle of you trying to
disprove the deity of Christ, that that
Jesus is God, you literally say that
Jesus is God?
Do you even know what you're saying? But
you You said, "Remember,
God the Father and God the Son stood
outside of time." So So, help me work
this out. If you stand outside of time
Matter of fact, let me let me just work
this out real quick.
So, this is what we're going to do.
We're going to go ahead and make a line
here,
and we're going to divide
the board here.
T for time
and E for eternity.
So, whatever is below this line is
within time. [music] Things like heaven,
earth,
uh silly
Hebrew Israelites.
>> [snorts]
>> In eternity, outside of time, above
time, we have
God.
Right?
Whatever is within time is created, had
a beginning, had a cause. [music]
Whatever is in eternity is uncreated,
eternal, infinite, has always existed.
You just said that what that God the Son
We'll do G, the Son, and G, the Father,
God the Father,
all stood outside of time.
So, when you say that God the Father and
God the Son stood outside of time, you
are acknowledging that both the Father
and the Son are uncreated. They do not
have a beginning. So, you're
contradicting yourself when you say that
Christ stood outside of time with the
Father, but also was created by the
Father. That makes no sense. Now, what
helps us out here is if we do some more
context reading. Let's see what the rest
of Colossians has to say about this. And
so, we continue reading, it says,
"He is the image of the invisible God,
the firstborn of all creation." Why is
he the firstborn, Paul? "For by him all
things were created in heaven and on
earth, visible and invisible, whether
thrones or dominions or rulers or
authorities. All things were created
through him and for him." Verse 17, "And
he is before all things, and in him all
things hold together." You left this
part out. Now, here's verse 18 that puts
the icing on the cake here. It says here
in verse 18, "And he is the head of the
body, the church. He is the beginning,
the firstborn from the dead, that in
everything he might be preeminent." Do
you see what it says here? It just told
you why Jesus is the firstborn.
Remember, it just called him the
firstborn of the dead. Does that mean
that he was the first to die? No. It
means that he is preeminent over all
creation, over those who have died, over
those who live, and those who are being
being raised to life. That's how you
read the Bible. That's good Bible
breakdown. Babe, was that the truth?
Yeah. Was that the truth? Yeah. Then he
lied. Let's get a little bit more detail
behind that.
>> [music]
>> Proverbs 8 and verse 22. It says, "The
Lord possessed me in the beginning of
his way, [music] before his works of
old. I was set up from everlasting, from
the beginning, or ever the earth was."
What does that [music] mean? Christ was
already with the Father before the earth
was. That was That's what makes it
possible for him to be the creator of
heaven and earth after [music] being the
firstborn created of God. So, babe,
how's that cooking class going? Good.
All right.
>> that. This brother is exhibiting on how
to cook yourself. In Proverbs 8, it's
talking about God's wisdom and how he
used wisdom to create the world, and
nothing in the verse said his wisdom was
created, but instead it says that the
Lord possessed him in the beginning of
his ways. Meaning that it had to exist.
Christ had to exist if he's the wisdom
of God before anything. You went to a
verse that proves Christ preexisted
before time. Now, let me help you out
with this. This is 1 Corinthians chapter
1, verse 24. Watch what it says here. It
says, "But to those who are called, both
Jews and Greeks, Christ, the power of
God and the wisdom of God." Now, I want
to ask you this, my brother. Was there
ever a time where God was without his
wisdom?
Was there ever a time where God's wisdom
did not exist? If Christ is the wisdom
of God, God's wisdom is infinite and
eternal, which would mean that Christ is
infinite and eternal. But, let's keep
going. Let's get one more, Avery. But,
Christ was not co-eternal with the
Father. In verse 24, it continues to
say, "When there were no depths, I was
brought forth." Meaning what? He was the
firstborn of all creation. Then, he
proceeded to make the rest of creation.
Wait, you hear that? My bad, the bread's
done.
And I don't want this trash bread.
Let's get some real bread on the track.
Now, this is going to cut this whole
idea that Jesus is created once and for
all. Our Hebrew Israelite brother's
going to agree that Jesus is the word
that existed with the Father in the
beginning. Now, watch what John chapter
1 verse 3 says about the word. It says,
"All things were made through him, and
without him was not anything made that
has been made." That's clear, and that's
a cut. He says that the word was used to
create everything, and there wasn't
anything that has been made that was
made without him. So, either Jesus was
used to create himself, if he was
created, or Jesus preexisted creation,
and therefore is eternal, uncreated,
just like the Father, while everything
else is created. It's a done deal.
>> When you read 1 Corinthians 11 and 3, it
talks about how Christ and God are not
equal. There is a hierarchy with God the
Father and God the Son. It reads, "But,
I would have you know, Avery, that the
head of every man is Christ, and the
head of the woman is the man, and the
head of Christ is God." So, there is a
hierarchy. They are not co-equal.
Neither are they co-eternal. The Trinity
is still false.
See, I told you he was going to get this
wrong earlier, didn't I? You have the
right words, but you didn't understand
the concepts. When we say that the
Father and the Son are co-eternal and
co-equal, we are saying that they are
equal in substance, in their nature.
They share one divine nature. Let me
break this down for you. So, the Father
and the Son are equal in their
substance. What they are is the same
exact thing. And I'm going to show you
that with the scripture. But, to address
the verse that you brought up, it
actually helps prove the point. For
example, it says that the head of every
woman is man. Now, are not both man and
woman human? Are they not equal in
humanity? So, just because there's a
difference in their role, doesn't mean
that there's a difference in their
nature. And so, Christ having the Father
as his head doesn't mean that the Father
and the Son have a different nature,
have a different being. It just means
that the that the Son humbles himself to
the Father, just like a wife humbles
herself to her husband. Simple as that.
It's really that easy. Now, let me give
you the scripture that backs this up,
cuz we're just going to read around
here. This is Hebrews chapter 1 verse 3.
This is going to cut you. Here it is.
Listen up. It says this about Jesus. He
is the radiance of the glory of God, and
the exact imprint of his nature. Do you
hear that? The exact imprint of his
nature. That means that the same nature
that the Father has, Jesus is the exact
same thing. So, they are equal in
nature, according to the Bible. But,
according to our Hebrew Israelites,
y'all trying to lie. Hey, cameraman, is
this the truth? It is the truth. IS IT
THE TRUTH? IT IS THE TRUTH. THEN, HE
LIED. IF y'all want to see more of this
type of content, where we're destroying
Hebrew Israelites, go ahead and check
out these videos over here, where I have
a debate with the Hebrew Israelite, and
I had a call-in show with the Hebrew
Israelites, and they panicked instantly.
[music]
Make sure you guys hit the like button,
subscribe, and let me know in the
comment section if y'all thought old boy
was cooking, or did he get fried.
Take care.